[Music]
don't work
you're coming on when love me 2:17 baby
my heart could still fall as hard at 23
I'm thinking bout how people fall in
love in mysterious ways maybe just the
touch of a hand me young people loving
you every single day I just wanna tell
you I am so honey now take me into your
nose kiss me under the light of a
thousand stars love maybe we found love
right where we are with my hands on him
[Music]
and a class on another when my hands
don't play the strings the same way I
know you will still love me the same
cause honey your soul could never grow
old its evergreen maybe uh smiles oh
[Music]
people fall in love in mysterious ways
maybe it's all part of a plan B your
people making the same mistakes hoping
that you'll understand
[Music]
baby thinking maybe we found a way
so this is um this is that secret
project that terrifies me it may not
seem like a lot I know I know it's got a
lot of mistakes and I know there's a lot
of stuff that I can improve on by my own
standards this is a big step forward for
me I haven't performed musically in
front of people since high school
and that was a nightmare so this was a
big psychological hurdle but you can get
to this point where where I've only been
taken this seriously for about three
months now but this is what I'm gonna be
doing on the tour like if you want more
tickets we also added second shows where
it's sold out so check out mark bar comm
or um or go go to link in the
description below there'll be stuff down
there that will show you I mean not the
whole tour we also have a comedy show
that we're doing with it but this is
this was a personal challenge for me
because it's one of those moments where
I know my weakness and my weakness is
this like performing a spin something
that's not just me going onstage and
talking but you guys know I can do till
the Sun Goes dead but when it comes to
like performing like this and knowing
it's not perfect then knowing I'm not
great it's I don't know I'm really proud
of myself and I think that's cool don't
expect my channel to suddenly change and
the only covers I I i do this because
it's a good challenge for me and it's a
great expression of creativity and it's
something that that really really drives
me in where a lot of my life i have
improved myself substantially this is
one of the areas that I've let myself
regress so I don't want to shy away from
it just because I'm afraid of
I want to pursue one hit it hard I want
to show you guys and I want to present
this to you because that's what
YouTube's all about like showing you me
and we're where I am not perfect I can
at least improve of it that's cool so
anyway let me know what you guys think
it's those could be bad could be good I
don't really care give it to me straight
I I'm my own worst critic anyway so not
like you guys could be any worse I think
I think this is fun and I want to do
what makes me happy and right now this
does even if it activates me to no one
when I'm wrong but it's cool thanks for
watching
[Music]